so if someone does have a cast that they
want to attach would you recommend that
they see an attorney or their do it
yourself you know nolo press you know
you can go and get your own I really
think that I really think that if you
are going to do this right you need to
be working with an attorney there is a
cost to doing business the right way a
lot of people want to kind of start up
and do their own thing you can take
those chances if your talent is your
cousin or your best friend of 20 years
maybe exactly you can roll the dice and
hope that they're loyal to you and that
that doesn't create a problem but as
with anything you'll have a difficult
time getting in to pitch or to present a
lot of the time if you don't have an
entertainment attorney or an agency
behind you the real reason for that is
well first of all you need to have
people who know what they're doing in
order to keep yourself and your concept
protected but moreover if you don't have
an agent or a manager again it's it's
the idea that there are firewalls to
prevent complete amateurs from just
eating up all the possible time in the
world with your development staff they
don't necessarily like to be approached
directly so it's just sort of an
arbitrary well we don't take submissions
unless it's through an agency or through
an entertainment attorney so there's a
bar that's then set for entry so that
you're not just sort of dragging in off
the street now there are places online I
don't know what the success rates have
been but there are places online that
say pitch your idea to us joke and
Biagio I think have something that's set
up that way with their site okay and
they're great yes producers they're
there they're wonderful people who
really love what it is that they do I
wouldn't have any trepidation about
presenting to them if I were new but
most people don't provide you with that
inroad sure so it sounds like not just
the story idea but also funds for
retainer for an attorney right and and
so you're looking at not going in hey in
a couple months I think I'm going to
really it sounds like almost
you're more in planning this out it's
possible but I will also tell you that
in working with an attorney there is a
way that you can work with an attorney
that doesn't require a lot of money
upfront if you have an idea and you're
working with an entertainment attorney
or wanting to work with an entertainment
attorney rather there are people who
will make your deal for you in exchange
for 5% of your show okay so that you're
not paying fees upfront but you're going
to be paying for it for the rest of the
run of the show if it actually sells
lots of entertainment attorneys that I
know do work that way
so it is an alternative but it is a lot
of money out of your pocket in the long
run compared to paying someone a few
hundred dollars an hour to do it right
you